that took you from a four to an eight if  nothing's changed what is it that takes  loving myself and and looking in the  mirror and not being disgusted at what I  see I understand that yeah so but that  doesn't you're you're not necessarily  being objective about how other people  view you right because isn't that what a  rating really is like what you think the  vast majority like like if I rated  myself one to ten I give myself a five I  think I'm normal looking and I just  think it's based on my results I think  if I was in eight nine or ten I would  have had modeling contracts because  people in the top 20 of beauty they get  they get modeling contracts